do you see him do you think a depressed
person could make this
no oh I'm fine it's just that life is
pointless and nothing matters and I'm
always tired also I can't sleep I'm
overeating none of my old Hobbies
interest me
I have done nothing wrong
ever
in my life
[Music]
it's a white flag and you may as well
start waving it right now you actually
won't be waiting is your decapitated
head on a stick in front of your weeping
mother
good Lord this is my friend Madison
she's amazing and she drove me here
it's beautiful
I've looked at this for five hours now
hi I just wanted you to know we're about
to be arrested ah look who hasn't had
Gay Thoughts what I love garbage jogging
is the worst Chris I mean I know it
keeps you healthy but God at what cost
stay back someone will die of fun
because we're smart
not to worry I have a permit
this just says I can do what I want
oh I have I have a medical condition all
right it's called caring too much
and it's incurable
I'm super chill all the time
I'm dead oh Lord is he eating soup on a
bench alone I have total faith in you
there's like a 30 chance they'll both
die
if I keep my body moving and my mind
occupied at all times I will avoid
falling into a bottomless pit of despair
it's about the cones
thank you so let's just go home yeah
let's go home no
no no everything hurts and I'm dying
[Applause]
stop
pooping
I know more than you
all right
honey follow me I'm distraught I kill
zones
trade me
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
good morning Ben oh I love nothing
this place is upstairs oh so just
because I can't go out with him someone
else can oh boy wow okay
thank you alcohol
yeah
I am 100 certain that I am zero percent
sure of what I'm going to do I'm never
going to be a cop
I'm gonna have to be a robber why am I
not crying okay I'm allergic to jerks my
anxiety has kept me up for over 50 hours
boom sadness that's the one
[Music]
if I was sick could I do this
what are you doing cartwheels
am I not doing them no treat yo so treat
yourself to 2011. from now on we'll be
using code names you can address me as
Eagle One and code name been there done
that April is currently doing that Donna
is it happened once in a dream Chris
codename if I had to pick a dude Ben is
Eagle two oh thank God look even Ben's
dancing
no thinking just stupid never half-assed
two things
whole ass one thing
how are you I'm dying I guess my
thoughts on abortion are
you know let's just all have a good time
oh my God
I'm gonna die someday I want to throw up
and kill myself get these balloons out
of here
buttery's my favorite food I'd work all
night if it meant nothing got done
she's the worst person I've ever met
I want to travel the world with her
I'm gonna go powder my nose amongst
other things
if you know what I mean
she gonna powder her vagina I need to go
lie down for 45 minutes no an hour
a full hour
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm leaning on my arm Andy
I'm holding the dog he's peeing he's now
peeing and putting him down no Ronnie
only has three legs
[Music]
I'm feeding your eagle
he's starving
I think we can agree that all wine
tastes the same and if you spend more
than five dollars on wine you are very
stupid no tragically we were both
heterosexual do you see the problem here
yes but I
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have
people
places
and things
I know this is a dire situation but I
swear to God this is like a crazy sex
fantasy for me
I regret nothing the end I like saying
no
it lowers their enthusiasm
and I'll have the number eight that's a
party platter it serves 12 people I know
what I'm about son I have no idea what
I'm doing but I know I'm doing it really
really well I ate a brownie once
at a party in college it was intense
it's kind of indescribable actually I
felt like I was floating
turns out there wasn't any pot in the
brownie it was just an insanely good
brownie I feel great I ran 5K this
morning
no I threw up in the shower
April you're like an angel with no wings
so like a person there are no
consequences to my selections anymore no
matter what I do literally nothing bad
can happen to me I'm like a white male
U.S senator
oh God did I Peak when I was 18. Leslie
I typed your symptoms into the thing up
here and it says you could have network
connectivity problems every time you
look up at the Moon I too will be
looking at a moon not the same Moon
obviously that's impossible all just
molecules floating around in random
patterns
devoid of meaning
thank you
I really needed this
for the
[Music]
how do I get it stage
okay
[Music]
no I didn't win but at least I didn't
make any new friendships you know my
code
hose before bros
uterus is before deuterous got it
ovaries before braveries I'm not afraid
of cops red carpet insole everywhere I
go I'm walking on red carpet
cancel Game of Thrones it's a crossover
hit it's not just for Fantasy
enthusiasts they're telling human
stories in a fantasy world
Mommy T you just missed the craziest of
crazies clubs girls dancing naked mom
argument police fleeing the seed hiding
in a dumpster coming here crashing on
your couch for a week because
technically I'm homeless